[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entre la colline de bougies que 2000
l'hôtel suisse d horizon bleu et evian
le ballet des hélicoptères a repris
chaque jour les journalistes en ont vu
descendre trois par trois les délégués
du gpr une conviction leur du
cessez-le-feu approchait mais une
conviction seulement autour de l'hôtel
du parc le secret reste est en effet
bien gardé
au casino où les négociateurs français
messieurs louis joxe robert buron et
jean de braye était venu se mêler aux
journalistes aucun renseignement n'a
percé la négociation simplement avancé
et sans doute était ce là l'essentiel
[Musique]
issy les moulineaux cependant était le
théâtre du plus odieux des attentats que
l'ol c'est comme il jusqu'ici en france
l'explosion d'une voiture piégée
faisaient trois morts deux gardiens de
la paix le vaguemestre d'une institution
religieuse et 47 blessées dont cinq
écoliers
[Musique]
la sauvagerie aveugle de ce crime devait
provoquer dès l'après-midi le
rassemblement de milliers de personnes
autour du maire d'issy les moulineaux la
foule devait flétrir les auteurs d'un
attentat qui a été perpétré dans un lieu
passant près d'un établissement public
face à un édifice public dont les locaux
abritent des cours d'enseignement
on n'allait rien le ministre des anciens
combattants monsieur raymond triboulet a
inauguré le parcours du souvenir ce
chemin que parcourt est une dernière
fois les patriotes pour aller se
recueillir à la chapelle avant de tomber
sur la butte des fusillés
[Musique]
le ministre s'est longuement recueilli
devant le mémorial de la france
combattante dédié à tous ceux qui avec
ou sans uniformes sont morts au combat
durant la guerre 39 45
[Musique]
c'est villefranche sur saône que la
fortune a choisi pour faire un homme
heureux monsieur qu'est peintre en
lettres s'est en effet trouvé du jour au
lendemain la tête de 40 millions
d'anciens francs grâce à la loterie
nationale nous lui avons demandé de nous
raconter son histoire
à l'autre je passais rue nationale puis
d'habitude je prenais un billet là
visuel puis tout d'un coup ça met plus
de rentrer dans le bus au tabac et j'ai
pris un entier le premier venu qui fait
devant moi que le lob mais j'ai j'ai
regardé sur le veulent ce journal
régional et j'ai constaté que j'avais eu
le tir est
numéro 1 85 mille six cent cinquante
groupes de je ne promets pas et puis
alors à ce moment là les amis m'ont dit
de verica a gagné le gros lot de gros
lot de la loterie qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé ce jour là à prendre a dit y est
entier j'avais l'intuition de gagner
d'ordinaire mans je prenais un dixième
et ce jour là comme j'avais cette
intuition qui étrenne entier pour
l'instant je continue mon travail a par
la suite je sais pas ce que je ferai
mais de toute façon j'achèterai encore
un billet de la loterie nationale
la vie moderne encombré de technico
précision de plus en plus poussée exige
des hommes qui la vivent mais attention
toujours en éveil un sang-froid parfait
une résistance nerveuse à toute épreuve
[Musique]
lorsque l'on considère les pilotes des
avions militaires ou civils en présence
des responsabilités qui sont les leurs
et dont dépend d'abord leur vie ensuite
celles qui leur sont confiées on imagine
sans peine quelle précision etc l
exactitude doivent avoir leurs réflexes
surtout aux vitesses que peuvent
atteindre les appareils à réaction pour
le mirage s'est plusieurs fois la
vitesse du son
si cette technique impeccable peut être
atteindre par un entraînement intensif
il va de soi que rien ne doit pouvoir
l'a troublé et l'alcool est sévèrement
exclu
mais ces conditions dont le caractère
impératif apparaît à l'évidence devant
le spectacle de dizaines de cadres ne
sont pas moins essentiel au reste du
monde
l'ouvrier devant son tour le chauffeur
devant son volant sont tributaires de la
même précision des réflexes de la même
résistance nerveuse au milieu des
conditions de la vie moderne
il reste que la précision des évolutions
des avions les plus rapides traduite
avec éloquence le merveilleux équilibre
physique nerveux et cérébral de ceux à
qui nous sont confiées et que ceci ne
saurait conserver sans la sobriété
prendre du style à l'objet appelé
l'inspiration sur les créateurs d'objets
voilà le but de cette exposition dont le
besoin se faisait sentir le coffret à
bijoux ya gagné des biceps sans doute
pour mieux défendre son trésor
la commode s'est mué en arbre à tiroirs
si depuis longtemps l'objet usuel
manifestait une médiocrité de forme et
d'invention lamentable voici qui va
changer tout cela
finie la psyché simplette d'autrefois ce
miroir aux alouettes c'est son nom
permet à la beauté de bien plus étrange
fantasmagorie
mais il ya d'autres découvertes à faire
dans cette exposition pour l'amateur qui
veut meubler sa maison selon les
concepts du nouveautés à la pointe même
de l'art message poétique
quelle étrange signe de connivence ne
laisserait pas la main rêver sur la
tablette de ce secrétaire fantastique et
cette baignoire arraché à une atlantide
disparu à quel sirène captive à quel
lorelei et elle par avance destinée même
le lit le lit banal d'hier est devenu à
la fois triomphal et parsifal hien le
meuble clé des anciens vaudeville à
recouvrer la grandeur des fables
classique et s'il affecte la forme d'un
demi cercle on peut tout de même
supposer qu'il se trouvera à 1 100
[Musique]
150 artistes ont donc réalisé sans
préjuger de techniciens ces formes
nouvelles rassemblement disparates
inattendu peut être scandaleux ou
dérisoire mais il n'empêche qu'il posera
des problèmes
troublera l'attention et c'est peut-être
à ce prix que des gens de métier
retrouverons une inspiration égarés et
que se dégagera un style original
puis de notre temps
quarts de finale de la coupe de france
ou par les passes opposant nancy maillot
blanc au stade ans
[Applaudissements]
les rémois que pas en tête numéro 9
n'ont décidément pas de chance cette
année chaque fois qu'il domine pas
l'adversaire il leur manque toujours le
petit coup de pouce du destin et quand
le destin serait de la partie c'est pour
précipiter les événements avant le début
de la partie a été marqué par la gente
amoureux pour nancy qui n'en espéraient
pas tant
[Musique]